let's get to audience questions we we
missed audience questions last week
right because of the mixed-up schedule
with the fair and cousins stuff and all
that yeah it's really a shame I'm gonna
have audience questions every single
week otherwise I think the audience gets
deprived of something they become irate
actually and you should see what
happened to my inbox over the weekend
all right first question is from penny
penny says what would be actual ways to
change the two-party duopoly in the
United States this is it's such a great
question but a lot of the things that
need to change are sort of interrelated
so to make some of these changes you
kind of need to make other changes but
bigger picture number one we need to
move in the direction of public
financing of Elections that's something
that needs to happen
ideally in combination with repealing
Citizens United I believe that
rank-choice voting also is going to if
it ever happens help break the two-party
duopoly that's where you can vote vote
for your sort of first choice candidate
and then if they are not viable in a
first tally of voting you've already
selected who your vote should then go to
and this is something that prevents the
fear that many of us have if there were
to be a not insane third party candidate
and I'll talk about that in a second
that I wanted to vote for if I were in a
swing state I would be scared to vote
for them because I might be ultimately
helping the Republican win whereas I
might prefer a third party candidate to
the Democrat I don't want to do
something that might actually make it
more likely that the Republican wins and
ranked choice voting solves that issue I
also think that there's something to and
this is I'm mentioning it like it's
nothing but it's such a major change to
our political system what about a
parliamentary system where you actually
see representation of parties in
proportion to the vote that they get
meaning if you like the Green Party and
I'm not a green party guy right but if
you like the green party if the green
party gets four percent of the national
vote in all House of Representatives
elections we might decide four percent
of the House of Representatives which
would be about 16 people
need to be from the Green Party right
that is another way that you can start
to chip away at the two-party duopoly
but that's clearly not gonna be
happening anytime soon
that's a pipe dream for sure I also
think quite frankly that you need to not
have insane or unqualified third party
candidates right and I mean if you go
back to 2016 the most the most prominent
third party candidates were Jill Stein
who's a nut and Gary Johnson who had
gaffe after gaffe and seemed generally
confused to find himself on a stage
being asked political questions like he
just stumbled upon running for president
accidentally when he was trying to get
his paper the morning paper so I think
that you also need quality third party
candidates and I think that sometimes
it's good that there's a desire for
third party candidates but I also think
that it's important to apply strict we
shouldn't lower our standards for a
candidate merely because they're outside
of the two-party duopoly right we want
to still continue to have good good
strict high standards for them those are
a few ideas but this is not stuff that's
gonna likely change yeah I think if the
two-party duopoly was to be shattered it
would have happened in 2016 like let's
say Donald Trump was denied the
Republican nomination
oh because they had a brokered
convention he probably would have ran as
a third party yeah or if Bernie Sanders
decided instead of endorsing Hillary
Clinton because I was robbed by the DNC
I'm going to run myself as a third party
sure then there would've been a lot of
support for either Trump or for Bernie
yeah I believe it's pretty clear from
the math that if Trump ran third party
in 2016 Hillary would have won yep if
Bernie ran third party in 2016
Trump would have won probably the
popular vote actually which he lost by
several million votes either way he won
the electoral vote so yes and that's why
you need the ranked choice voting
because it would solve that problem yes
a well I'm voting for Bernie as an
independent if he doesn't have enough
votes to be President then I want my
vote shifted over to Hillary Clinton for
example I just think maybe that's what
it would have taken to blow up the
entire system you know you know
supporting Bernie Sanders may have been
the election of Donald Trump or
supporting Trump may have been the
election of Hillary Clinton yeah if it's
all for the sake of
ending this whole two-party system that
we had it could have been a good thing I
think there will be another opportunity
I don't I mean I think you're right that
2016 was a particularly interesting year
for a third-party candidate to get 15
percent of the vote 18 percent of the
vote didn't happen though because of the
way that it shook out those are my ideas
send me yours about ways to break apart
the two-party system